bonsoir madame friend hausse par jal est
ce qu'il est est ce qu il était
nécessaire mme adam freeland aujourd'hui
de bonifier la location canadienne pour
enfin il ya des gens qui trouvent que ça
ressemble à un cadeau électoral
non ce n'est pas ça moi même en tant que
mère des trois enfants
je comprends très très bien comment la
crise est difficile pour les familles
canaille et surtout les familles qui ont
des petites enfants surtout les familles
avec des petites enfants ou la mère le
père les parents veut travailler
c'est une période très très difficile
alors je pense que c'est absolument
approprié pour nous d'aider un peu plus
ces familles et c'est ce qu'on va faire
pourquoi ne pas aider alors dans cette
logique lot davantage les années qu'il
ya dix années qui aurait aimé aussi
avoir une bonification supplémentaire de
leur revenu de retraite
on a fait beaucoup pour les années déjà
on vous savez et dans cet énoncé
aujourd'hui on a aussi dire que on va
donner encore une milliards de dollars
aux provinces et territoires pour
assurer la sécurité la santé et des
soins de longue durée
moi je pense que c'est l'aide le plus
important qu'on peut et qu'on doit
donner à nos amis vous vous offrez un
programme de prêts pour les restaurants
du crédit pour les restaurants les
hôtels la culture il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui disait c'est des
subventions dont on a besoin en effet
remet présentement on est déjà très
endetté
pourquoi vous optez pour dit prêt et non
pas sur des pour des subventions
gérald comme vous savez très bien
on a aussi des subventions on a annoncé
aujourd'hui que la subvention salariés
elle a que le niveau maximum sera 75
pour cent pour la subvention salle
arrière commençant cette semaine les
entreprises pour commencer à recevoir la
subvention pour le loyer a le niveau
maximum pour cette subvention et 65%
mais on a aussi créé un programme pour
aider de plus les entreprises qui sont
ciblés par des mesures de confinement ou
additionnel 20 5% alors par exemple au
mont à montréal par exemple les
entreprises peut avoir 90% du son loyer
à payer par le fédéral alors 90 % du
loyer
un souhait au ps pour soi du les
salaires et en habillant en peut avoir
aussi sept nouveaux programmes
je pense que c'est beaucoup gerald je
pense que c'est beaucoup adam freeland
vous avez tout à fait raison mais ce qui
est beaucoup aussi celle adepte des
entreprises
les entreprises sont très endettés est
ce que ça ne vous inquiète pas pour la
structure de l'économie pour la suite
des choses a évidemment gérald et une du
mes cibles et du noeud pap et remettez
des blessures un emploi économie
je veux que on finit avec le coran à
virus avec une économie qui est assez
fort qui a le potentiel pour une relance
et c'est pour cette raison que on a
beaucoup de programmes de subventions et
je pense que quand on part des autres
programmes
on doit vraiment comprendre que ils sont
en addition des programmes de
subventions pourquoi vous ne devez pas
directement air canada westjet 3 ap au
delà de la subvention salariale partout
dans le monde dans les grandes économies
on a annoncé une aide précise dirigé
ciblées pour les compagnies aériennes
pourquoi vous ne faites pas ça pour
comprendre comment exactement on doit
travailler avec les grandes compagnies
aériennes on doit comprendre en détail
leur situation financière et on est en
train de certains on est en train de
discuter du parlait avec les grandes
compagnies aériennes mais je suis élu
est une faute que on veut je veux
souligner une chose que le ministre
marque renault a déjà dit que c'est très
important pour beaucoup beaucoup des
canailles est d'avoir une compétence une
compensation juste pour les billets
qu'ils ont acheté qu'ils ont été annulés
et pour notre gouvernement à voir cette
compensation est vraiment une priorité
il n'y a rien non plus sur les
transferts un santé supplémentaires
demandées par les provinces où sont les
besoins en matière de santé pourquoi on
a déjà donné beaucoup aux provinces et
territoires
et c'est une bonne chose on a commencé
avec 500 millions de dollars pour la
santé
après ça on a ajouté à 19,9 milliards de
dollars pour que la relance sécuritaire
on a ajouté après sa du milliard du
dollars pour la relance scolaire
sécuritaire dont on a déjà parlé
aujourd'hui vous et moi a dû une
milliards de dollars on addition pour
les soins de longue durée et on va faire
plus pour acheter à les soins de à
provisions monde et pe a on va aussi et
en a acheté des d'accès alors en a déjà
fait beaucoup
on continuera de faire beaucoup pour la
santé et moi je pense que notre beau
maintenant non
on travaille avec les provinces et
territoires doit être très très ciblée
sur la côte 19 et la lutte contre la
cofidis de 20 mo en terminant est ce
qu'il y aura un budget 2000 21 22 oui il
n'y a pas eu un budget en 2020 21 alors
je me permets de poser la question on
comprend pourquoi cela dit merci
beaucoup madame free donne aucun nom
c'est une bonne question est pour cette
raison j'ai donné une réponse très
claire
absolument merci bien on voit